so now we are going to answer some fan
questions yes okay yes it is alright
great so um first a question from at
Benny factor on Twitter asks do you
prefer San Pellegrino or Perrier or some
other sparkling mineral water that we've
never heard of at Benny factor on
Twitter asks what kind of sparkling
water - I prefer will in fact Benny the
answer is quite complex it differs
according to my mood I can tell you this
if I am drinking sparkling water on its
own I might prefer Sun Pellegrino
which is an Italian sparkling water I
like some Pellegrino under that
circumstance I could tell you that my
favorite sparkling water to drink after
espresso is the German Gerolsteiner
water which is quite a freak of nature
the mineral content is so incredibly
high over 2,000 parts per million total
dissolved solids also known as TDs and
the mineral content is so high in fact
that if you were to drink a liter of it
a day you would have a quarter of your
daily requirement of magnesium magnesium
is a very difficult mineral to obtain
supplementing orally is inefficient
I rub magnesium lotion all over my body
to make use of transdermal or absorption
so you people don't understand
sometimes they use artificial products
that they rub on their skin like certain
sunscreens and lotions and they say it's
ok I'm not eating it it's just on my
skin but whatever you put on your skin
goes into your blood streams for example
people wear a nicotine patch and other
medication patches for a very direct
absorption and so the blood stream so
for example cavemen used to swim in the
ocean all the time in the ocean is a
rich source of magnesium that
transdermal exposure gave the cavemen
the magnesium they needed now swimming
in the ocean has fallen out of favor for
most of us and therefore other methods
are necessary organ meats have also
fallen out of favor another rich dietary
source of magnesium nevertheless
Gerolsteiner to me has such a dense
minerality that perfectly suits the
bitter complex
city that you get from drinking and
espresso Wow okay and where do you get
that from the Internet the great thing
about Gerolsteiner here's it's so
readily available it can be found at
every Trader Joe's store that I've been
to it could be founded Whole Foods I
think it costs a dollar forty nine at
trader Joe a dollar sixty nine at Whole
Foods however if you buy a case of
Gerolsteiner water at Whole Foods they
give you a unadvertised 10% case
discount bringing the price down
seventeen cents per liter